rumba last fall when everybody got all
up in arms about how the iPhone 7 didn't
have a headphone jack that was dumb
really all it did was show us how truly
great wireless headphones really are and
there are tons of wireless headphones
out there now some look like these some
others look like these and then there
are the new funky ones that look like
these if you ask me the most exciting
ones especially if you're thinking about
the future where we're all wearing
computers in our ears look like these
the Apple earpods and the Doppler labs
here one the air pods are the more
straightforward of the two there are a
hundred and sixty bucks and they're just
headphones you can double tap to talk to
Siri or tap once to pause your music
it's nifty
play some music but basically they're
just headphones - all the tangley cables
the here ones are something else
I first tried these almost two years ago
and since then
Doppler Labs has raised a bunch of money
on Kickstarter partnered with Hans
Zimmer and change the product a lot
these $300 buds do all the headphone
things Siri and music and phone calls
and all that stuff and do it just about
as well as the air pods but the coolest
thing they do is let you control the
volume of the real world think of them
almost like super-powered noise cancer
you put them on open up the app and
swipe down and suddenly the world gets
quiet or swipe up and it gets loud
you can add reverb to all the sounds you
hear or make everything go fuzzy and
loud and go deaf in like five minutes
there are multiple mics in each bud and
they're using some really impressive
signal processing to figure out what
you're hearing and change it in real
time the most useful practical things
are the filters with one tap you can
automatically tune out the sounds of an
airplane or subway or quiet down all the
obnoxious chatter boxes in your office
it's really hard to understand until you
try but I was standing by the subway the
other day and as soon as I pressed the
button all the roaring and whooshing
just completely disappeared I literally
said whoa out loud you can also mix real
world sound with whatever music or
podcast you're listening to
[Music]
if you leave the volume at zero even
when you're playing music you'll still
hear everything happening around you
[Music]
it all comes through a little mechanical
like you're suddenly in a video game or
something but you can play music and
still hear cars coming just fine it's
kind of like you're carrying a speaker
in front of you except that the people
around you won't hate your guts really
all this tech does work honestly much
better than I expected
but there's a big trade-offs to all the
here ones features the interface is sort
of awkward you can do a few things by
tapping on the headphones but not all of
them and there's no easy way to learn
what's what if you want to listen to
music with no outside sound which is how
most people want to listen to music you
have to go into the app and turn the
volume all the way down which is weird
and unintuitive you think tapping on the
bud would pause your music and it does
but with these it also resets everything
to normal so you're hearing real world
sound again it's meant for you to be
able to quickly listen to someone but it
feels really strange
the biggest problem by far is the
battery these buds last two hours if
that before you have to put them back in
the charging case the case is good for
about three charges but if you're a
heavy listener you're going to be
charging this whole kit every single
night the air pods get more than double
that battery life which is a big deal
the here ones are also kind of confusing
just to set up the app walks you through
it but it takes a while and you have to
jump back and forth to settings all the
time air pods on the other hand are just
beautifully simple it's like magic you
open the case and poof you're connected
really the decision you're making here
is between the easiest most convenient
pair of headphones you've ever worn the
air pods versus the amazing and
definitely not quite finished future to
hear once it's going to be an
interesting race between these two
dopler needs to make the here ones a
little more intuitive and a little
simpler and get that $300 price down
meanwhile Apple needs to figure out how
to do more of the super computational
stuff in its own earbuds and hopefully
make them look less like many
toothbrushes
neither is perfect but you know what
wireless headphones are awesome
so get used to this look because you're
going to have a computer in your ear
before you know it